this is jungle podcast number 369 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willing good
evening Echo good evening there's a
famous speech
I think Tim Ferriss
I might be the first person that I heard
talk about this speech
the speech is called this is water it's
by a guy named David Foster Wallace
and it's a graduation speech you know
when people are graduating from college
I'm not going to go into David Foster
Wallace's whole life he was uh a
professor he was a writer
he was an author of books and he battled
with depression his whole life and he
eventually killed himself which is awful
horrible
but that may at some point maybe we'll
get into that
but
I want to talk about his speech a little
bit because it opens up an idea that
I've been
I've been engaged with for a while now
so his speech starts off like this
greetings parents and congratulations to
kenyon's graduating class of 2005.
there are these two young fish swimming
along and they happen to meet an older
fish swimming the other way who nods at
them and says morning boys how's the
water
and the two young fish swim on for a bit
and then eventually one of them looks
over at the other and goes what the hell
is water
and
so the point of this
story is that you know we're in water
and we're so used to the water we're so
encompassed in the water that we don't
even know that we're not we don't notice
it
now what does this have to do with
anything well
how does this apply I mean there's
clearly there's a there's a topic that
we can get into about appreciating life
and that's the water that you're in and
you can just be not appreciative of it
but I was thinking about it from a
different perspective
and we've talked about before on this
podcast and you've probably heard me say
this before the best way to beat someone
in a game
is if they don't even know that they're
playing the game What's the best way to
beat someone right they don't even know
that it's happening
and you're out maneuvering them because
they don't know what's happening and
then you beat them I mean it'd be like
imagine you're pre-ju Jitsu like you
didn't know anything about Jiu Jitsu and
you got into
a a fight with someone
and they were doing things you don't
even know what they're doing I mean
they're getting the mountain you don't
even know what that is so it's not
you're just beating them they don't even
know what's happening
foreign
so the best way to win a competition is
for the opponent to not know that there
is a competition Sun sues we've had we
haven't had some too on this podcast
he's been dead for a while but
you know he he talked about the goal is
to win without fighting
right the win without fighting when we
want to fight
this is also the indirect approach right
I don't want to get go head to head
so
several months ago
I was talking one of my friends and
someone that I spend time with and and
talk to
not all the time but fairly regularly
and we were talking through some of his
trials and tribulations
and I started talking about the game
and and maybe it was
the way that I was referencing it or
the way I said it
and I talked about it look in leadership
strategy and tactics I talk about
playing the game which is a very
specific reference to playing the game
in a work environment interacting with
other people but when I was talking to
this friend of mine
I I was talking about the game you know
he was going through some stuff and I
was talking about the game and as I'm
watching his face as I'm talking about
the game
that he's engaged in I realized he
didn't know he was in the game
just like the fish not realizing they're
in the water so there's things going on
in his life there's things going on with
his work there's things going on with
his marriage
and there's Maneuvers being made and I
can see him because he's telling me what
they are he's telling but he doesn't
realize that it's that those are moves
foreign
like hey you realize that this is a game
right
and he just gave me that Blank Stare and
I realized no he didn't he didn't know
this was a game
and over the last several months I've
had a bunch of conversations not a bunch
but I've had
several will say conversations like this
and I realize that a lot of people don't
get
this idea
of the game that they're in
and I know so I wanted to spend some
time talking about this because I think
a lot of people don't realize
I think a lot of people don't realize
that they're in a game
and that there is a game in fact there's
multiple games going on
and they're in them you're in them
I'm in them
so
if you don't realize that you're in a
game you're not gonna win
you you things are happening and and
you're not gonna win you have to
recognize that you're in a game and and
you actually have to recognize that
you're in multiple games
well remember a long time ago we had a
conversation about ecosystems right that
there's different ecosystems in the
world I actually had this conversation
with Andrew huberman recently you know
talking about the ecosystem he's in the
ecosystem of Academia yeah
he's uh he's a professor at Stanford
he's got a lab like really impressive to
some people there's some people that
literally do not know where Stanford is
there are some people that don't care
what kind of schooling you went to
there's Jiu Jitsu ecosystem oh I'm a
purple belt I'm a brown belt I'm there's
people that there's people that don't
understand that to them a black belt in
Jiu Jitsu is the same as a black belt in
karate they just like whatever right
there's ecosystems at work the SEAL
Teams is an ecosystem different guys in
there they're trying to maneuver trying
to get to the to the to the to the top
of that pyramid of the ecosystem and so
there's all these ecosystems and in
those there's games right there's games
that are being played there's work games
there's relationships
there's Financial games during the
financial game
there's Fitness
there's a status game
there's a materialistic game there's all
these games are going in and all those
are going on and all those are like
subordinate games that are going on in
your life possibly you might not care
about them
you know you might not be playing one of
those games that's okay
you might not be playing the Jiu Jitsu
game you don't care about Juju you might
not be playing the financial game that's
okay
but you might be
he might be playing some of those
subordinate games
and then there's the Supreme game
that you are playing
which is life which is life viewed as a
game now
there's sort of a diminishing
tone right to say that something's a
game right there's a diminishing tone
because guess what else is a game
tic-tac-toe yeah right tic-tac-toe is a
game uh Shoots and Ladders is a game
[__] yeah right I
so so sometimes I've said this before
this isn't a game right I've said that
before
in certain contexts okay this isn't a
game
so to now I'm sitting here saying
everything's a game but what we're
talking I'm not trying to devalue I'm
not trying to diminish I'm not trying to
depreciate
life and I'm not trying to devalue
depreciate or diminish some of these get
like relationship games like oh it's a
game to you you see what I'm saying yeah
there's a negative connotation but
it depends on the definition that you're
going to use and I actually looked
around and see if there was another
better word but there actually isn't
yeah there's just multiple definitions
yes a game can be tic-tac-toe yes game
can be Shoots and Ladders yes game can
be football game and to compare you know
people get mad compare football to like
combat like what are you doing that's
not common and it's true so you can't
say and I'm not so I'm not trying to
take everything and compare it to Shoots
and Ladders or what's the candy game
maybe that was Shoots and Ladders Candy
Crush no Candy Land I forget there's
there's another game of Candyland that
was like up there with Chutes and
Ladders when I was a kid Okay so
you could take that definition this sort
of frivolous game that you play for fun
but
there's some definition of game that
means you've got
a competition
based on rules
where you're trying to score
points or earn value in order to beat an
opponent
that's a game which again that's what
combat combat is the most serious of
games
and that's what it is it's a game
there's rules we're trying to maneuver
we're trying to follow the rules while
we beat the opponent it's competition
and if you think about life similar
because in life guess what there's rules
and you can break some of the rules of
Life there could be consequences you can
actually choose different you can have
different rules in your life than I have
in my life we could have different rules
so you actually have some say in the set
of rules that you're going to go by
right you get somebody with no morals
um these uh
people that rip off billions of dollars
from other people that guy's operating
by a different set of rules than a
normal person yeah
should be punished severely for those
actions but that's what he he was
following the rules that he thought or
maybe he was breaking them right
but there's rules that's what's
happening in life you've got rules that
you're following you are you have goals
that you're trying to achieve
so you're trying to score goals or earn
points that's happening
most likely you're going to have to
compete with others to achieve your goal
most likely
whether you're a caveman and we're
trying to survive and you're trying to
eat you know we just killed a a damn
woolly mammoth
and now we gotta fight over who gets
more meat there's limited resources or
where you know you're running a business
I'm running a bit you're making widgets
I'm making widgets we got to compete
so
when
when I'm talking about game the game of
life or really these sub games these
subordinate games in life don't think of
the lowest definition so if you're
already mad someone's mad at me or the
life isn't a game there's they deleted
the podcast right life is not a game
yeah oh but it is
but don't think of that low kind of base
definition think of the straightforward
definition a competition executed
according to rules where the goal is to
achieve some kind of victory
and by the way the victory is also
defined by rules
right because for some reason they make
a field goal worth this many points and
a touchdown worth that many points those
are just they just made that up yeah
so depending on what rules you put in
your life you winning might look
different for you and to me and that's
okay
that's the thing we're not disparaging
the set of rules you're playing or the
goals that you have or the goals that
I'm playing or the rules that I'm
playing are the goals that I have I'm
not disparaging those things
they might just might be different what
we have to watch out for is you have to
make sure that you do know the rules
that you're going to play by you have to
make sure you know what you're trying to
achieve what does Victory look like for
you
so
that's that's what's happening now
during
um this conversation that I have with
this friend of mine he eventually got
that look on his face that he understood
that okay I get it
I'm playing the game
I'm in a game
he understood it but he don't he just
kind of like realized it
and then he started asking me questions
like what are the rules of the game
how do you win the game
where do you focus
do you ever walk away
can you surrender is it a marathon is it
like he started asking me detailed
questions
about the game
and I've been thinking
for a while about these things I want to
spend some time addressing these on
maybe a podcast or two maybe seven
podcasts maybe 12 I guess I don't know
but
let's start with this
how do you know you're in a game
how do you know well the short answer is
you are you you act absolutely are in a
game and in order to see that you have
to take a step back
and look at this and to get here
what I recommend I recommend this often
as a tool for detachment and that is to
take a step back and actually write
things down
actually put pen to paper
if you don't know that you're in a game
right now take a step back sit down
and and write down ask yourself some
good questions
what
are my objectives
like if you're looking at your life or
you're looking at your relationship or
you're looking at your job
you need to take a step back and say
wait a second what are my objectives
because if you don't know what your
objectives are I mean you definitely
don't know you're in a game I mean
imagine you're walking around a piece of
grass
and all of a sudden people go running by
you and one of them's holding the ball
like you don't know what they're doing
right maybe you should grab that dude
and put him to the ground but but you
don't even know what he's doing yeah you
don't know what direction he's going you
know there's big there's lines on the
grass there's numbers around them 10 20
30 40.
right you don't know what they mean
so write down okay what
okay I get it I'm trying to get this
ball into that
area of grass that's painted red okay
think of think of how your whole world
improves if you're standing on a piece
of grass you have no idea what's going
on people running around they're kicking
things they're throwing things and you
don't know what's happening yeah but as
soon as you go oh I gotta I'm trying to
these guys with the red shirts on are
going against the guys with the white
shirts on
and we're trying to get this ball into
that
red area Okay think of how much
more productive you can be
in that scenario yeah just knowing that
just knowing that so how many people are
sitting there on the field of life and
they don't even know what direction
they're going they don't know what the
objective is they don't know what their
objective is
so the first step you take is you
actually write down okay
here's what I'm trying here's where I'm
trying to go here's what I'm trying to
do this is my objective
and then you try and figure out okay
what are the rules here like what are
some of the rules you have to obey
because there's rules there's societal
rules there's religious rules there's
family Rules there's rules that are in
place yeah
that you you can't just uh if the goal
is to get money well you can't just
steal it you can try but you get caught
there's gonna be consequences you can't
you know you have relationships with
your family
you need to protect those relationships
with your family in most cases those are
rules that you write down
then you start figuring out okay what
strategies can I use what tactics can I
use now that I know what my objective is
what should I actually be doing
tactically
on a day-to-day week-to-week basis to
try and progress towards this goal that
I just figured out I had
and then write those things down
and I think what you will see as you
start to write down
these objectives and these rules and
these strategies and these tactics I
think what you'll start to realize is
that you'll start to see oh there's a
couple different games going on here
there's a couple different games going
on here
probably a real obvious one is work
it's also an obvious one because a lot
of times you can see what your objective
is Oh I wanna
get paid I want to get promoted I want
to move into a leadership position or I
want to grow this but you know what
something like that so that generally
speaking work is a little bit more
identifiable not always because you talk
to some people you know we go into
company's National front oh what do you
go you know talk to a Frontline manager
oh what what are your goals here
uh
make good money this quarter they don't
have any long-term goals they're gonna
be strategic goals oh what's the goal of
the company oh make money this quarter
like they so that means they're not
thinking strategic they're thinking
tactical but they at least will have
some idea in most cases I mean imagine
you were a bouncer sure right back in
the day
did you ever think to yourself all right
what am I trying to do here
yeah I mean there was a point where it
hit me really hard and I started
thinking that I was gone soon after that
yeah yeah because you started thinking
wait a second what like if I win this
game yeah
what do I get yeah
what do I put into it and what do I get
that's another thing to think about is
like what is not just what's the
objective and what's the victory but
what do I get for that victory yeah
because
a paycheck on Sunday
and a wasted Friday wasted Saturday
you know hanging around scene you
shouldn't really it's not really
progressing your life you start
realizing oh this what what am I doing
here so you actually had that Revelation
yes
how long did it take you to make the
decision to to bail uh well actually
it's funny because even right when you
just said bouncer it hit me so clearly
uh
[Music]
but it did hit me so at first yeah
you're like just floating you're like
the game if you even recognized which I
didn't because I just needed a job I had
experience so it's easy to get so I got
it and then it was just good fun so it
was literally just moment to moment day
to day and short term oh yeah
gratification like daily basis like
literally basis nightly literally
nightly
and that went on you know early 20s who
cares you know kind of a thing is as far
as how it went for me anyway and then
yeah once I hit mid-20s that's when it
started to hit me whoa like I've been
here like
two years years and what do you have to
show for you nothing same spot but which
was fine because it's still fun I'm
still young all this stuff but you know
when you hit 25ish you're kind of like
oh you see older people in that scene
and you're like oh that person's like
kind of older cool fine but I didn't
feel that that's where I wanted to be
kind of a thing all that stuff started
to creep in your my mind or whatever and
then yeah you start to realize like okay
I should I should at least pay attention
to the Future like long medium whatever
future and then I but I've been not
paying attention for so long that I
wasn't even looking outside of my like
trajectory you know so I started making
goals within that same trajectory maybe
I'll be a manager maybe I'll gain some
skills here and bro they were all about
it the all the people you know my
superiors they're all about it they're
like oh yeah cool and then so I started
to kind of pursue that a little bit and
then after a while I'll meet with you
about your career yeah yeah because they
got you they think oh yeah we got them
yep it fully did like oh yeah and just
the kind of guy we we need yeah yeah
essentially you know you know what that
manager paycheck looks like
this is such a perfect this is exactly
what I'm talking about yeah this is
exactly what I'm talking about and you
had a little moment this happens to a
lot of people you know you see you see
the person that's doing what you're
doing
but they're 10 years older than you and
you think wait a second
hey you have a Moment of clarity where
you go wait a second
that some people have a Moment of
clarity wait a second that's going to be
me some people say oh no that'll never
happen to me yeah
but in order for it to not happen you've
got to get you gotta you got to make
some adjustments yes so this is exactly
what I'm talking about like this is
exactly what I'm talking about yeah from
the work perspective you're in a work
job you're doing your job and you're
looking and you start realizing okay
what is this game that I'm playing
because you're you are on the field yeah
but there's plays happening there's
things going on you don't even know
what's
you don't know what's happening yeah so
that's a good step to take now here's
another one here's another game that
you're in whether you want to be in it
or not and you should know you're in
health yeah
health is a game that you're in
and if you don't recognize that you're
in this game again that's when you look
at somebody that's 10 years older than
you and they're not in good physical
condition they're having health problems
they look terrible they feel terrible
and that did they did they 10 years
prior say you know what I really want to
do I really want to put on 48 pounds of
you know fat I want I want my heart rate
to go
catastrophic I want to just look like
crap and feel like crap yeah there's
zero people say that yeah and yet there
they are why they didn't realize that
they were in a game yeah they didn't
realize that there's rules to that game
like here's the rules there's rules you
got to follow if you don't follow them
you break those rules you're gonna look
up and you won't be you won't have
achieved your objective
and if you don't know that there's an
objective you better start paying
attention to this podcast right now at
this moment in time
uh
relationships right and this is another
one let's talk about this with my
daughter because when you say oh it's a
relationship it's a game total negative
connotation right yeah but what if I
said hey you know I got a relationship
with Echo Charles he's a friend of mine
it's a game here's what I'm trying to do
trying to build a good relationship
trying to build trust like all those
things are positive yeah
and yet it's a game because you're
you've got maneuvers you got to make you
gotta follow certain rules in order to
build that trust in order to build that
respect so all those things are going on
and then you've got life and you've got
you know Legacy and whatnot
and and I think so so we got these
categories
and what are your pillars you got your
pillars what are your pillars what are
they pillars there's eight of them
there's five what are your pills well
there's four that and they're both
pillars okay they have Partners okay
like Partners
um okay uh health and physical
capability are there two okay so and
then so how physically
um your income and what you do with your
time
so they can their kind of Partners is
interesting interesting oh your
spirituality and your worldview
that's another two okay and then your
relationships friendly and romantic okay
these are you know these are things that
if you broke those down health is a game
income is a game
spirituality I'm not sure how we pinned
that one down I'm not sure what you mean
by that your place in the world okay so
it's game understanding your place in
the world yeah yeah and where you're
going in the world yeah to me more
importantly like hey where am I going in
the world yeah well I I've always
thought of it in this way where
um you know because a lot of times
spirituality that's another just I mean
just you asking that really that's
really indicative of how I think a lot
of people kind of read our spirituality
it has different meanings for different
people so I thought about that and I
think just understanding your place in
the world you know how like if you look
at the world just all of existence that
you understand as one big puzzle like
where are you in that puzzle you know
that little piece because you fit to the
pieces next to you somehow and so how do
you fit and how does that puzzle kind of
form as a whole you know compared to
where you are in it so it's just like
like that like your place in the world
yes
but a lot that's sort of like saying I
know what my place is on the field yeah
but you got to know what's happening on
the field like you've got to understand
what's going on what's the importance of
it and yeah yeah absolutely you're right
so when I say when I was talking about
right taking a moment to write these
things down to me it's sort of like uh
what happens when people say I'm gonna
write down my New Year's resolution
write down my goals I go you hear a lot
of people they'll say oh if you got to
write down your goals in order for them
to come true there's that's that's a
good tactic
and what when you do that you're
actually writing down a goal you're sort
of you're sort of clarifying the game
you're clarifying the objective of the
game so that's when you write down your
New Year's resolution you're you're
saying okay I'm entering this game yeah
and for that alone can help you saying
oh there's a game going on here I eat
junk food every night and if I keep
eating junk food I'm gonna lose this
game of Health yeah so writing it down
and saying okay
I want to lose weight
I want to be more healthy here's the
rules I gotta follow yeah and then all
of a sudden you've defined the game and
now you can start to make progress
whereas if you don't do that you know
what the hell is going on in your life
so what games are you on are you in are
we in well as you mentioned like job
work income
what are the rules there well you're
going to have you got to earn money
right you want to get promoted possibly
not everyone wants to get promoted get
learn some kind of a skill right there's
a there's a positive benefit to learning
some kind of a skill that gives you some
kind of job security
and then what are the rules inside that
game
you got some rules like there's lit
actual rules be on time for work right
these are actual rules but there's a
uniform you got to wear yeah
um there's a treatment of others you
can't use this word or whatever the HR
will come and get you yes right
and then you got the job itself
and the tasks that you've got to
complete and the skills that you've got
to learn and the projects that you got
to complete
and and then you've got
the game that's going on at work because
if you build good relationships with
people the right people you can support
each other
and if you're hey does that make you an
ass kisser if you build a good
relationship with your boss and you take
care of your boss and make your boss
look good no no actually you're doing a
good job
and your boss will then most likely take
care of you yeah your your relation and
you brought that up really early where
it's like um ass kisser right like brown
nose or whatever like that just that
idea when you say forming a good
relationship up the change that's how
you put it
and I'm like wait a second like you
gotta there's a difference between being
a brown noser and building a good
relationship so don't think of it as
this is my what I'm saying in my head
right to gain a better understanding of
what you're saying so building a
relationship with someone is just
whether it's up the chain down the chain
your neighbor your wife your kids
whatever it's it's all essentially the
same you do it in different ways I mean
different people different ways but it's
essentially the same approach where it's
like you're you want to build an actual
relationship 100 you're not trying to
make them you're not trying to please
them at every moment necessarily you're
trying to build a two-way street good
relationship like anything so yeah Nolan
I don't even think brown nosing is
building a good relationship yeah yeah
well there's some people that are some
people that are susceptible they like to
get brown-nosed right but what's funny
is like let's say you're a big brown
noser with me and I was the big boss man
I actually know you're a brown noser
he's just trying to kiss my ass exactly
right and actually you started to say
that and I went kind of deep one a few
days anyway
um thinking about that because I know
some brown nosers and some of them are
like man that guy's so nice he's so nice
to everybody but at the same time like
the re you know because the purpose of
building a relationship has a smell
antenna has a smell so Brad you don't
trust them that much you like them and
then you know you'd go into stuff where
um what's the expression that a good
neighbor or a good barbecue I don't know
the concealed teams yeah yeah like it's
like that that like you like them you
totally like them you never do anything
mean to this guy it's so nice but
yeah you know and that's what I felt
about like brown noses whatever no
matter how nice they are so I don't
think that's an effective way to build a
relationship yeah
this one of the earlier I think this was
a couple years ago now
but it's worth reiterating
is this the game you want to play when
it comes to work is this the game you
want to play because
you spend a lot of time with your job
and if you hate it that's not healthy
it's not healthy
you should be playing a game when it
comes to work that you like to play yeah
right so if you like pouring concrete
then that's great and you're and you
pour concrete for it I mean think of how
awesome that is
if you like
software engineering
and you're a software engineer I mean
it's hey if you like being in the SEAL
Teams I was in the SEAL Teams I love
being in the SEAL Teams what a freaking
great job I didn't I never went to work
a day in my life yeah
so do you want to actually play this
game is something you should assess
and by the way we're going to get this
on on all aspects of this right because
you're going to be in relationship games
do you do you want to be in that
relationship game you're going to be in
life games that do you want to be
playing that particular
field yeah
but for work is what you're doing
gratifying
is it gratifying to you do you get done
with a day and say damn that was a good
day I really got along I I made progress
I made the world a little bit better
today I made my world a little bit
better I made my clients World a little
bit better I made the highway a little
bit better pouring concrete yeah like
what are you doing are you proud of it
and then and this is the thing that came
up a couple years ago
does this game
score the way you want it to score and
the what came up with I had two friends
that were both working two extremely
capable friends
meaning
extremely smart
uh charismatic you know just good really
good both of them were men really good
guys
both extremely hard workers these are 70
80 hour a week people 100 hour a week
whatever's needed
and they were both
capped out
from a from a financial income
perspective meaning they were making as
much money as they could make
playing that game all right and the way
I explained it to both of them luckily I
had the two conversations within a
couple weeks of each other but it's like
you could be the best soccer player in
the world
and how many soccer goals could you
score a game
maybe one maybe two maybe
but if you're a basketball player you
might be scoring 30 40 50 points a game
well there's some jobs that you work
an 80-hour week
and you make sixty four thousand dollars
a year those those jobs exist for real
There's jobs at work you work
20 hours a week and you make 500 000 a
year yeah
so if you work 100 hours a week you're
gonna make you know multiples more than
that
so
figure out if the game that you're in
from a job perspective write it down is
this the game I want to be in what are
the objectives how many points can I
score is it worth my time like Echo
sitting around as a bouncer at 23 years
old it's like okay hey this is fun but
as soon as you take a step back and say
wait is this gratifying wait a second
how much money can I make
and part of the way we're keeping score
is money
so if I can't make a ton of money and I
can't really progress what am I doing on
the field right now why am I playing
this game
so when it comes to work
ask yourself that question ask yourself
all these questions
is this the game you want to play
from an employment from a job from an
entrepreneurial perspective is this a
game you want to play now we get we're
talking about health
which is it what's interesting about
health is you don't have to follow any
of the rules
no one's going to enforce the rules on
you I mean you can get addicted to
heroin and you can literally do heroin
until you die yeah that's that's you can
do that yeah
but there are rules that we know you can
follow you know you can follow good
healthy diet you can follow exercise you
can do the proper amount of rest and
Recovery
and if you don't know that you're
playing a game there you're going to
have problems
relationships
so at Echelon front last couple years
I've been talking a lot about
relationships and what a relationship is
and what a relationship is to me is
trust listen respect and influence
meaning
if you and I don't trust each other
there's no relationship if you and I
don't listen to each other there's no
relationship have you and I don't
respect each other there's no
relationship if you and I have no
influence over each other there's no
relationship but if we do trust each
other if we do listen to each other if
we do respect each other if we do
influence other then we got a
relationship and obviously there's a
whole bunch of Shades of Gray in there
different gradients of of how strong our
relationship is
but that's what that's what we're
dealing with so
you got friends
you want to have you want to build
friendships
you want to build good relationship
friendships you know there's a I think
the movie is called the town where the
dude comes in he's like hey we're gonna
go somewhere we're going to hurt some
people and we can never talk it about it
again and the Dude Looks back at him and
says whose car are we taking yeah you
kind of want some friends like that
right that's the kind of friends you
want
you also want to have a friend that's
like hey bro is this a good move that
we're about to make is it worth the risk
what are we doing it for is this your
ego are you just emotional right you see
what I'm saying you want to have
somebody that's going to push back
against your your your what you consider
to be your good ideas yeah
you want to make sure
that your friends really want the best
for you
they they like it when you win they love
it when you win they want they like it
more when you win than when they win
right that's always nice
it's always nice when you've got a
friend that says oh you're winning and
they're happy it's so bizarre
that you can have friends that when you
win they don't like it bro it's spooky
actually and it it's not just friends
too like you know if you come across a
family scenario where you know it's
revealed to you that you know maybe
they're not as supportive you know yeah
it's uh it's bizarre for sure but it's
like kind of spooky because you know
like someone's your friend and maybe you
know
in under on a certain circumstance like
you've only been through so many things
with them a lot for sure but let's say
there's certain circumstances you
haven't been in with them then they get
revealed to be you know like easy one
the easy one like if something good
happens to you like big major life thing
you know and then you could tell they're
not happy you're like damn this whole
[__] time you've been feeling that
way do you know like bro it's bad man
yeah it can jam you up yeah that when
when I got my house and Stoner came like
I had a couple friends come over
when I first got my house
and uh the house where I live now and
it's it's it's in an optimal spot let's
say right I would agree with it's an
optimal position geographically on Earth
and like the first guy that came over
was like
oh I forget what the little criticism he
made but it was a devastating in his
mind you know
oh this salt water is going to eat
everything yep you know like that was
like for him
bro like how could you even live here
the salt spray from the ocean is going
to really damage your your whole life
yeah your whole life I'm like well you
know I'll rotate some gear out I think
I'll be all right but that and I saw I
had several people hit me with that
negativity yeah Stoner came over like he
showed up he's like bro we are set
you're so he's calling it weep right
because if we got this yeah right
actually yeah but but what a crazy thing
to think about so
when we talk about these relationship as
being a game well if you've got a friend
that doesn't want you to win you're not
winning the game yeah yeah if you've got
friends that are supportive of you or
doing everything they're going to help
you you got you're winning the game
same thing with your uh you know your
your relationship whether it's a spouse
whether it's a girlfriend boyfriend type
scenario
this is sort of your business partner in
life in in
in a lot of aspects of your life yeah
so what kind of trust what kind of you
know respect do you have for each other
how much do you influence other how much
do you listen to each other where are
you at because if you got a spouse that
you don't respect you're not winning the
game if they don't respect you you're
not winning if they don't listen to you
they're not winning the game if you
don't listen to them like those are all
things so if you don't understand that
if you don't understand that that's part
of the game that you're playing you're
gonna lose the game
you're gonna lose the game
um we got kids right you start having
kids
that's
part of the scenario too
and so then there's there's influences
that you have on your kids and what
influences are you having on them
and are they negative or are they
positive and if you don't understand if
you're not paying attention to that
if you're not watching it
all of a sudden you look up and you've
made some major mistakes
and you got a kid running off the rails
over here yeah
so when it comes to this relational
aspect thing of friends of spouses of
girlfriends or boyfriends of kids
by the way kids same thing you want them
to listen to you listen to them you want
them to trust you you have to trust them
you want them to treat you with respect
you better treat them with respect
to cast all this away by saying like you
know the classic expression I'm sure
you've said it to a bunch of young
ladies in your day stop playing games
with me no I'll put it everywhere okay
but you know you know the uh that's a
that's like a common uh phrase a really
negative like stop playing games with me
yeah yeah
and if you view this idea of playing a
game with relationships just from the
fact that you like playing a game and
manipulating of course it's a negative
connotation but if you look at the game
is to build bonds if you look at the
game as to build trust if you look
a game to build a true partner in life
then it's a positive thing yeah
yeah that really that's funny you bring
that up or
the cording
phase in a relationship right dating in
that part the courting part of it it's
like
there's that big game that you're
talking about but then there's a couple
of maybe two levels of psychological
game within the game
so and there are rules just and there
are like ways to score and all this
other stuff like and it kind of is like
an actual game in that way but it is for
the good the it's for the greater good
and that's what you have to look at is
is your end goal
to manipulate some other person right
then then then you're playing the wrong
game yeah hey I can say that that
ultimately you may get a short-term
gratification but ultimately you're
playing the wrong game if your goal is
to manipulate someone take advantage of
them listen you might win a short-term
game oh I got this girl to do this for
me yeah where are you going to be long
term yeah that's why you have to take a
step back and write down what it is
you're trying to achieve because you go
through a bunch of hollow relationships
like that you haven't progressed in life
yeah and you end up with a bunch of
baggage yeah that's not going to help
you we're we're playing a game not of
manipulation that's not what we're
talking like there's a there's like a
famous book that's called the game right
yeah it's like a pickup artist it's
called the game okay and um that's like
one of those things it's like oh if you
say this you act this way it's like
giving pointers to guys so they can go
and manipulate yeah uh girls into
basically you know sleeping with yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure I haven't read it
but I'm pretty sure that's like that's
what it is so that's a not what we're
talking about
and look that could be a game that
you're playing when you're 23 years old
yeah right you could be playing that
game
but if you're playing that game right
now at 23 years old take a step back and
figure out where that's going to put you
in the long run that's what you need to
figure out
because there's a bigger more Superior
game that you should be playing
and think about that
the other
the other game that we're dealing with
is is
everyone's dealing with is your mental
health
um which in my opinion it's kind of
rooted in everything we just talked
about like physical health right if you
have if you're if you're not physically
healthy
it's going to be harder for you to keep
your mental health on Peak right on
point
your job gratification right if you're
miserable at work what does that do to
you for mental health if you're if
you're miserable all day long that's not
beneficial to your mental health
if you are in bad relationships
that's not beneficial
for your mental health so all these
things are impacting your mental health
one thing that I've noticed
is that
a big part from what I've seen a big
part of Mental Health
and being a good place from a mental
health perspective
is taking ownership
and
I've found
that people who take ownership of their
actions have better mental health and
obviously this falls into right in line
with the book extreme ownership
but when I look how many people have I
met over the last
10 years or I guess when did
extreme ownership came out in 2015 it's
2022 right now so the past seven years
how many people have I met
that have
for a lack of a better phrase turned
their lives around from a mental health
perspective by taking ownership of
what's going on in their world by saying
oh because guess what how do you get bad
physical health
you don't take ownership of your health
you blame the work you blame the time
you blame the district
how do you take ownership of your or how
do you have bad satisfaction at work
well you blame other people and you
don't get promoted because you don't
think that anyone likes you because it's
all their fault how do you end up in a
bad relationship well you go I ended up
here and now I can't get out it's like
no people that take ownership of what's
going on and by the way when you say oh
yeah you know I got a DUI and I lost my
license and that made me lose my job and
my life sucks now man okay
the person that goes yup you know what I
really screwed up here's what I did I
went you know I got a DUI and I lost my
job here's what I'm doing now that's my
fault obviously I stopped drinking I'm
never drinking again here's my new job
it's low paying but I know that there's
a path for me to re uh you know promote
over time here's the way I'm getting
around I went and got an e-bike you know
and now I can get to this new job I have
so people that take ownership of what's
going on in their world are absolutely
going to have in my opinion a better
Mental Health
and this is something that I've seen
a lot of
and I've seen it help so many people
I've seen it help so many people to say
oh yeah I had this you know
my mom got sick my dad got sick my kid
got sick my job got lost like all those
problems and going okay here's what I
can do about it here's how I can fix it
here's how I can move forward
and you know that that one about the mom
getting sick about the dad getting sick
about the kid getting sick
when you take that oh well now there's
I'm you know woe is me and and believe
me look I've talked to
countless people that have been in that
situation
my kid got sick I mean I'm talking like
bad diseases cancer like serious
diseases the ones that say oh yeah this
is what
this is what hit me this is what hit my
family here's how I went on offense
here's what I did and said oh I can't
believe this happened to me when people
take ownership of how they respond to
things it helps their mental health so
much just like taking action being on
offense instead of being on defense is
so much better for your mindset yeah
and if you go through life not taking
ownership
being a victim of what's happening to
you it's much harder on your mental
health than saying okay God dealt a bad
hand here's what I'm gonna do
you feel like it's like a control thing
like you know and you say this where
it's like um the the a big motivator if
not the biggest motivator for people is
controlling their own destiny so is on a
like for lack better term on a
fundamental level isn't that kind of
what it comes down to like control like
if something if life is happening to
someone they feel they're not in control
all these bad things and they're not in
control if they were they wouldn't
happen you know but they're just
essentially like missing the the idea
that you are in control of a bunch of
things you're kind of not in control of
a bunch of things for sure there's
things you can't control yeah and then
using the things you can control to
control the situation kind of thing and
usually we're just blind
and I'm trying to think of any situation
where I was like unhappy or whatever
it's like you're just more blind to it
it's not that they're not there like the
elements you can control you're just
blind to the idea that hey you can
control this whole thing and then when
you kind of go from there and this is
kind of what I'm I'm kind of hopefully
kind of figuring out where that's where
the ownership
comes in yeah where it's like hey this
mistake
because you start if you start blaming
other people you automatically kind of
relinquish control of everything yes
where it's like hey this thing messed up
it's not my fault you know like it's too
bad it's like you know out of my control
but now everything looking forward is
not your control either
but if you look at it like the opposite
way you're kind of like oh wait I can
control the outcome you know take
ownership of how you respond to things
yeah for sure so you get horrible news
and you take ownership of how you
respond to it there are absolutely
things in the world that you cannot
control there's absolutely things in the
world that you cannot control absolutely
of course
and then it's like okay how what can I
control and let me focus on the things I
can control
and then move forward to the best of my
ability and respond to whatever thing I
can't control in the best possible way
and if you don't do that
then you're just on defense and being on
defense is like you know imagine you're
uh imagine you're a mouse in a cage in a
in a let's say in a room and there's a
cat in there well let's say there's
three of you mice and there's a cat in
there how do you feel like you're
constantly scared you're constantly
reacting you have no control
if you're the cat you're kind of like
good to go right he's walking around you
know like looking for food looking for
dinner
and and so what are you gonna do you're
gonna be the cat you're gonna be the
mouse you're gonna be the Predator
you're gonna be the prey yeah and if
you're a mouse and you're in that room
instead of going well this is horrible
why couldn't I be a big you know 12
pound animal with claws and teeth
instead you're like hey you know what I
can't be a big animal but you know what
I can do is dig a little hole through
this part of the wall and I can have a
place to hide and that way this guy
can't get me and then be good I got
control now and by the way inside this
wall we got some insulation in there
we're gonna build some nice beds and
we're gonna make a little life for us
hell yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
so there's a different attitude yeah
when you take on what can you control oh
I can burrow into this wall a little bit
yeah and I can actually get control
inside behind this thing and I won't let
this cat in here and we're good to go
yeah
man that's uh that hits me a lot when I
get injured where you know when you
first get engine you're like well never
did Jiu Jitsu it sucks this whole thing
I can't go train for a hiding yeah I
said to how long he's like oh freaking
you know it's six eight months or you're
like oh my gosh it's the end of the
world it's 16 months a long time yeah
especially when it's not like you
literally do not have the option to go
train six eight months I've never been
through that actually yeah so but I also
think too lifting like bro I can't lift
like how look if I have a torn bicep
toward ACL turn whatever it's like bro I
can never I can't do squats anymore or
bicep I can not only can I not do curls
End of the World by the way
I can't do shoulder I can't do bet
there's a lot that your biceps do you
know so in your mind you're like I can't
do any like I can't lift why even like
one of my dude dude half jumping jacket
like it doesn't make sense but if you
for real think like hey no anything
regarding my bicep in any kind of
intensity or whatever sure we can't
control that right now it'll come back
but we can't control that right now
we're gonna do literally everything else
as ours as we can bro you'd be surprised
how much good stuff you can get in fact
you said you mentioned this
you probably don't know the impact it
had on me it made me feel real good but
remember last time I tore my bicep the
second one I was like I forget what
exactly how I phrase it but I was like
hey can you even tell that this is this
has been torn because the first one the
whole arm was like a noodle because I
kind of I didn't approach it the same
way approached this last one but I was
like can you even tell you're like
you're like oh yeah I just figured
you're you know whatever like you made a
joke first but then you're like no
actually I can't really tell at all
aside from the bandage that I wore from
the first week like you you're like oh
did you get surgery this is after you
had surgery after I had surgery yeah
yeah did you think you I could tell I
thought my arm was a noodle again but
then I I would say you know I'd see
myself on video and stuff and bro I
can't even tell and when you can't use
the bicep at all for like six months
right it does a lot of like it shrinks a
lot but if you do like everything you
can genuinely everything you can bro
it's like minimal see I'm saying and
that's like a good like what do you call
metaphor whatever for how it can be you
know you'd just be surprised how much
you can still control you know what I'm
saying the book Superstar Watts you know
otherwise known as the Bible of lifting
but the funny things like oh how do you
get how do you get big arms
squats how do you get a big neck squats
how do you get big forearms squats like
that's kind of the the response sure oh
yeah uh but yes it is a huge
thing to think about how you can respond
and also we do have there are obviously
things we can't control but we can
usually control a lot more than we than
we think yeah then they'll control a lot
more
that's going on in your world you
control a lot more than you think you
can yeah and so
keeping that in mind
this is part of the game of Mental
Health
and what's scariest about mental health
I think
of all these is that I think it's the
hardest one to track for yourself right
it's the hardest one to go oh I don't
feel good about myself I don't feel like
I'm in a good spot I think it's hard for
people to track that so it's worth once
again taking a step back and writing
down like okay I got all these I got my
physical health I got my job how
satisfying is my job how satisfying are
my relationships
where am I at
how do I feel at the end of the day
what's my stress levels
so
these are
things to think about and when you start
talking about when you start taking all
these things when you start taking a job
and you work
and your health and your Fitness and
your relationships
that you're in
with including friends including family
then you add mental health in that you
take all those things together
foreign you get life
and that's the Supreme game right that's
the big game the big game that we're
playing
and obviously There are rules in life
and as I started off by saying we have a
lot of say over the rules
of the game that we're gonna play where
where they come from
what set of rules are you going to
follow
what rules are going to bring you the
most gratification how wait how do you
even pick those rules
and then once we figured out game the
game that we are going to play
how do we win
and I think we'll talk about that on the
next the next
podcast so I realize you
kind of were in this mode early on and
that's when it hit me it dawned upon me
oh there's this long term and short-term
game going on
and there's also I don't know maybe if
this is more just a different take on
the same thing but there's like a small
picture in Big Picture game going on as
well yeah
so it's like short-term long-term big
picture small picture and once you
realize that's going on then you can
begin kind of the Journey of discovery
of how many of that how many elements in
life that applies to it applies
everything by the way but you don't you
don't it doesn't land on you till you
really realize okay this is going on and
then everything you do everything you're
interested in everything you say
in a way
is like that applies to it short-term
long-term game big picture small picture
game yeah I think it's it's I had a
similar conversation with Dave Burke
good deal Dave yeah and it's about Hooda
Loops right observe oriented side and
act and you've got one you got a new
Loop that you're running like on right
now about a business decision that
you're making with a client that you're
gonna you know talk to later today man
either you're running but you're running
a ooda loop about that whole division in
the company
and you're running an ooda Loop about
the whole company and you're running an
ooda Loop about your whole it's the same
thing you're running an ooda loop on
your life like what Observer where I'm
in life right now it's a similar thing
where am I at life observe what's going
on Orient yourself where you sit in that
big picture yeah but you've got all
these different ooda loops and you're
running them at the same time okay so
it's the same thing that's what that's
why
having this idea recognizing I was I was
actually explaining this to my daughter
and like you could see as I was
explaining it to her
you could see the light bulb come on
right like yes like oh this is a game oh
that's a game oh this other thing's a
game and what she said to me is she said
oh she said
that's why you're detached that's why
you're able to detach that's why you
don't get mad because this is just a
game yeah and you're observing what's
happening in the game and so you're not
going to get emotional because like oh
well
when you lose a point
do you run off the field and break down
no you're like okay lost a point we'll
make some adjustments like that's the
way it is
and by the way there's very all these
little subordinate games that are being
played ultimately compared to the
Supreme game they don't really matter
that much yeah so you can kind of shrug
them off yeah now listen we all know
that there's people getting wrapped up
in a game right they get wrapped up
they're 17 years old they got the
girlfriend they get wrapped up in that
one relationship game and when she dumps
them that guy's freaking done wants to
kill himself or does kill himself right
everybody that's watched that goes hey
man that was this one little game that
you were playing what are you doing
don't don't don't give it up over one
little game
that's like you're playing you know
Heist Pop Warner football yeah
you lose a game
end of the world no it's not the end of
the world it's one game what that's
another thing my daughter pointed I was
like oh she goes oh you learn from these
games yes
yes you do I do learn from the game part
of the game is oh I made a mistake in
the game cool I just learned and I won't
make that mistake again yeah
so there's a Detachment that comes from
this view that's very powerful to
utilize just to say oh
didn't get the job oh that's okay that's
part of the game and I didn't win in
this particular game at that particular
moment I learned from it here's what I'm
gonna do relationship didn't work out oh
okay we'll kind of learn from that yeah
not not the end of the world not the
last game I'm ever gonna play no those
are gonna be actually a lot more games
and so crazy how if you put things into
perspective it's like oh man Things
become so clear you know what we're
freaking distracted that's the thing
because like you know okay you know when
you're young you save money right like I
don't know you want to buy a slingshot
or something like this
and you're like okay I gotta save up
twelve dollars to buy that slingshot
boom you're already aware of the game
that you're playing short term long term
you know like oh the Jolly Rancher for
sale over there bro I'm not gonna buy
that Jolly Rancher because I'm saving
that one dollar
but it is party because that's part of
the game two right discipline just
understanding the long term is more
important than the short term and being
able to follow through that's all it is
in a nutshell so you kind of know that's
an example of like knowing the game but
you get distracted like the Jolly
Rancher is like super delicious or
someone you know something like this
um that's part of the opponent
kind of jamming you up so like
you know how entertainment in general
social media whatever TV Netflix all
this stuff these are all like
distractions trying to distract you from
your whatever your goals you're winning
your game or whatever in whatever
capacity but at the same time it's part
of someone else's game to win their game
yeah and I think the biggest and this
was kind of the opening discussion we
had here the the worst thing to have
happen
is you you're in the water and you don't
know that you're in the water yeah
you're in the game you don't know that
you're in the game so this should be for
some people this will be hearing what
we're talking about should be a
prospective shift for their life
realizing that they're in a game that
there's rules that there's objectives
that you're going to have opponents
you're going to have allies all these
things are going on yeah they're all
going on and if you don't recognize it
you're going to come up short this is
what entertainment is okay in football
there's um there's a lot of unboxing
there's faints you know and all this
stuff so in football there's like
there's a bunch of different places
obviously but there's a play where
the quarterback will fake to the
fullback and then he'll kind of roll out
and do some stuff so social media
Netflix all that stuff what that is is
the fake they make you like pay
attention to that thing while they and
they use you they totally use you to pay
attention to this one thing maybe your
people on your team are gonna pay
attention to you a little bit plus that
fake so they're gonna all do what I want
them to do while we go do this other
thing meanwhile you're losing your game
or winning our game using you as a pawn
that's what that's what social media is
oh yeah you're definitely getting played
you're definitely getting they're
playing a game and if you're sitting
there and it's eating up your brain yeah
they're they're winning the game you
don't even you probably don't even know
you're in the game you don't realize
that they're taking your information and
selling it and all that stuff that's
what's going on oh yeah the whole game
like yeah all around all around
so pay attention to it we will continue
this on the next podcast
um in the meantime you know what you're
going to need on the health side you're
going to need to be healthy you need
some healthy fuel get yourself some
Jocko fuel jockoffuel.com drinking some
energy drinks right now yep I'm on the
Mulk train right here ready how's that
banana banana all day banana cream
there's a difference there's a
difference yeah banana cream is always
good in my opinion pretty much
everything I've never tasted a banana
cream anything that wasn't good this is
no exception so tasty it's you know
what's nice about the Mulk like I got
done training yesterday and I got done
training the day before and I got done
training the day before yeah and every
day when I got the tree on the way out I
just went ahead and just grabbed the
smoke you're good just just on the road
on the drive home yeah seven minute
drive home here's 30 grams of protein
yeah right how good is that and by the
way as you know on the weekends so
Friday Saturday well I guess Friday I
happen to get some training in this
Friday but Friday Saturday Sunday
I'm I'm waking up lifting hell yeah
running
coming to jiu jitsu no food yeah so oh
damn no food after that okay I might
have some I might have like a handful of
nuts or whatever yeah like I have what I
want to go I don't want to go trade with
the big like gut full of food how long
between end of the running lifting
scenario and the Jujitsu long in between
hour and a half two hours something like
this okay all right that's why I have
like a little maybe a handful of nuts
maybe I'll have you know I've been
having a lot lately is uh just
mozzarella cheese with some olive oil
and balsamic vinegar on it oh yeah bro I
love those things yeah but yeah the
Sarah made these yesterday and the day
before and she doesn't always because
you've got the basil on there yes
I like the tomatoes but uh for real man
even that I don't really want to have
that I want to come to jiu jitsu and I
want to have like a pretty empty stomach
so you know what I will on the way I'll
have a go yeah and you know Wes like
first of all Wes is just like already
too strong and too flexible and too good
at jiu-jitsu and he rolls in and he's
pounding a goal like he he's doing it in
my face or like trying to get it trying
to get in my head right he's like oh
he's pounding that thing I'm like dude
so then I started getting after it yeah
you know so I now I have a goal on the
drive here and I have a I have a goal on
the drive here I have a mock on the way
home yeah this is a great combo perfect
this is a great combo so jocklefuel.com
go to Vitamin Shop go to Wawa go to the
military commissaries go to Hannaford
go to HEB
by the way everyone in Texas that's been
going to HEB just getting it on we
appreciate it through dominating an HEB
so rolling in there Murphy's uh Meyer up
in the midwest hey and by the way a lot
of people hit me up like hey they don't
have this in there tell the store to say
hey look there's no go there's no
whatever whatever it is that they're
missing just just let them know you want
it and they'll hook it up so
we're making the best possible stuff you
can make yeah so get it it'll help you
in all aspects of your life yeah talk
about that that health and capability
game it was Peter yeah it was Peter Tia
where he was like saying he was he was
making a broader point but he was like
hey
if you want to like kick ass at 80 you
can't be like slacking at 70 or whatever
the numbers were they might have been
different but it's basically like hey
this is a long-term play you can't just
Jam yourself up and ignore it or
whatever and then once you start getting
older then try to jump on the train it's
like bro it doesn't you just you can
still be jammed up now see what I'm
saying yeah you know you got to pay
attention because it's a little bit you
lose a little bit at a time you know I
was talking to Bert soaring sure and
we were just talking about lifting and
you know he's he's just about beast but
basically I was saying hey if there's
like an extra you know when you get
injured and you can't do a particular
exercise like for instance when my arm
was hurt I couldn't do overhead squats
for like a long period of time yeah
after Dean Lister freaking
crashed crushed my arm
showing a move by the way Dean Lester
anyways I couldn't like lock my arms out
for an overhead Squat and for months I
couldn't do an overhead squat and so
then when I eventually could do me and
it was really humbling it was like PVC
pipe you know you're like thinking God
but well it's not gonna burn like hey
don't don't submit don't surrender that
movement because it's really easy to
just say I that's something I can no
longer do yeah and it and it happens a
little bit at a time right it does not
it's like one day I don't know if I can
really do them today
and then the next time maybe you can't
really do them yeah so just pay
attention to that man true you gotta
that physical part that works out this
physical game that we're talking about
it's a it's a it's a long-term strategic
game that's that's the death of a
Thousand Cuts and and look you know what
you're eventually gonna lose yeah like
100 you're gonna lose right yeah like
I'm gonna
at this point it actually looks like I
might get old and die I usually think I
wouldn't get old enough at this point it
kind of looks like I might get old and
die so you you know you're gonna go off
death of a Thousand Cuts but you can
postpone one cut today yeah push one cut
off today that's another day you went
you know it's another day without that
little that little razor cut into your
your tendons and whatnot so cute that's
what we're doing jockofuel.com check it
out yep all the best supplements in the
world factually actually everyone knows
it also origin USA
geez
for jujitsu rash guards American
All-American made stuff it's a big deal
jeans boots t-shirts
just everything that you need
you can get originusa.com and we're
building all in America
we got factories here we got an awesome
Workforce
so that's what we're doing we're not
enslaving people no like they are doing
overseas working a 13 year old girl in a
sweat shop for a dollar a month that's
what's going on if you buy those other
brands
I'm gonna go ahead and say don't do that
I'm gonna say support America support
freedom
so there you go originusa.com get some
also
uh Jocko the store is called Jocko
stores where you can represent while
we're on this path that's a thing too oh
yeah
discipline equals Frito good this
attitude of uh moving on you know in the
face of adversity knowing what you can
can control and what you can't guess
what the good Mantra kind of stands for
nonetheless you want to represent that's
where you do it also we have a shirt
Locker which is a subscription scenario
you want a new shirt every month
different designs good though
kind of like nice when you know other
people are out there we're all kind of
wearing the same yes unique shirt on the
same team so there you go it's true uh
subscribe to the podcast don't forget
about Jocko underground 8.18 cents a
month that's our our own platform you
might be listening to it on right now we
appreciate it that's how we're gonna
stay alive if we ever get banned who
knows some wild [__] going on right now
so be careful we got a YouTube channel
origin USA has a YouTube channel we got
psychological warfare we've got Flipside
canvas got a bunch of books
that I've written so if you want to
check those out also we have Jocko
publishing we got Holly Holly McKay's
book
um
Echelon front leadership consultancy we
saw problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com if you need help in any
organization if you want to come to our
Live Events check those out we also have
extreme ownership Academy
so you can take the lessons that we
learned and you can apply them to your
life
that's what that's about you're not
going to get good
at leadership you're not going to
understand decision making you're not
going to understand how to overcome
adversity by
going to the gym one time
you need that that rep those reps so go
to extreme ownership.com I'm on there
answering questions live
extreme ownership.com also if you want
to help service members you want to help
active and retire we just had Mama Leon
you know her great organization
America's Mighty Warriors dot org she's
continuing Mark Lee's Legacy Marcus
still helping his teammates through that
organization and also don't forget about
heroes and horses Micah Fink up there in
the wilderness right now who knows what
he's doing he's probably on a freaking
horse somewhere chasing a Grizzly down
with a with a with a stick
getting ready to get some so if you want
to find yourself he can help you out
heroesandhorses.org he's helping a lot
of veterans up there you can connect
with us on the interwebs echo's at Echo
Charles he's back on Twitter by the way
after you got
it's a long he made mistakes
you know
made mistakes just dumb mistakes
honestly it's hard I'm normally not
critical maybe I'm a little bit oh yeah
you're critical sometimes so some dumb
mistakes got made price was paid paid
and we're moving forward moving forward
you and your 13
Twitter followers now all right there
you go and I am at Jocko willink watch
out for the algorithm right yes they're
playing a game on you yeah we'll be part
of that game
um thanks to all the folks out there in
uniform around the world fighting to
protect freedom
you allow us to be doing what we're
doing right now we humbly thank you for
your service and also thanks to our
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
all the First Responders out there you
keep us safe here at home we thank you
for your service as well and everyone
else out there pay attention to the
water that you're in
there's games going on you're in them
some of them are important
some of them are just for fun
and the big one
life
this is not a frolicking game of
amusement
but it's a game with rules and goals and
winners and losers
so make sure you know what games you are
playing
so you can win
and we will continue that conversation
next time and until then this is Echo
and Jocko
out